[Musique]
actualité aujourd'hui notamment marquée
par les opposantes à sa lumière qui vont
à quattre la pression sur le
gouvernement pour leur sixième ken
mobilisation à lapproche la rentrée ici
vous savez tout se passa ni terre
fabrice c'est un vrai comme il l'a dit
sur son compte twitter fabrice est un
vrai c'est un puriste c'est pas un mec
qui raconte des histoires c'est pas un
mec qui joue un rôle et fabrice n'a pas
de personnalité donc ce matin il
m'appelle et me dit
je pensais que vous demande rien aux
ministres de la santé un allègement du
pass sanitaires pour être sûr de remplir
nos salles fernando parce que je n'ai
pas les restrictions mais celle-là vous
la comprenez elle est très basse et très
bien ce qu'il a fait ce qu'ils ont fait
au moins ça a boosté les gens pour se
faire vacciner là avec ce numéro vous
avez et j'ai encore essayé quand même
vous avez une personne qui décrochent
qui vous aide à prendre rendez vous soit
pour le site plus proche de chez vous et
au bout de combien de temps elle déco cg
très rapide c'est très rapide ont
regardé sous la dictée donc j'espère
qu'on peut aller et puis voilà c'est
vraiment un accompagnement
pour la prise de rendez-vous
que il y a des listes d'attentes encore
pour se faire vacciner on ne peut pas se
faire vacciner si je décide aujourd'hui
de me faire maxillaire je parle pas de
paris région parisienne mais en province
renseignez-vous jeune homme sort
vainqueur attendre 48 heures à tout mais
alors
non on va tous on va conserver cette
direct sur le plateau de télématin on va
les vérifier que ça répondait et dont on
vous appelle pour prendre rendez vous
c'est comme ça que ça se passe
allô
allô allô
franck j'ai fait peur au monsieur
les gens adorent la contrainte la règle
et l'interdît mois dans le train je fais
exprès de mettre des heures à boire ma
bouteille d'eau uniquement pour faire
progresser la chine sur le plan
psychologique dans leur rapport aux
masques et à leurs propres stocks donc
je suis là comme en thuringe et même
nmnm mais à part un petit pan j'ai prise
j'ai pris le chemin de fer ce week-end
je suis allée angoulême parce que
à la fin guéret je vous jure à la fin
j'ai voulu l'enregistrer je sais pas si
ça message du contrôleur ou si c'est un
message de la sncf à la fin quand
j'arrive à angoulême 1 messieurs la
planète vous remercie d'avoir choisi le
louvre un jeu monte dans le train avec
mon pass sanitaire est hélas j'enlève
mon masque je le mets même pas sur mon
menton parce que j'ai remarqué sur mon
menton ils sont un peu tranquilliser se
disent que je vais le relever vraiment
je n'aurais je le pose et tac tac tac et
je vois ce que tu sais combien temps et
je vois ceux qui veulent lutter tout en
plus je suis un club 4 et je vois les
gens j'en vois certains qui commence à
paniquer tout la planète vous remercie
d'avoir choisi le train puisque le train
consomment moins de co2
je sais que quand on a un toc
le la meilleure façon d'en sortir c'est
de se confronter de s'exposer à sont
donc je les expose à leur toque pour que
petit à petit sorte de l'intox
restrictions de libérer chez c'est la
question du député en marge de base au
bout d'un moment quand même pas rien à
dire vrai thaksin et je vous avais des
vous avez des journalistes monsieur vous
êtes un peu oui est un petit régime
venir si bien c'est jean tigana
on
va peut-être remonter nicolas non mais
ça lui franchement la non violence
physique honnêtement
quand je vois que cette dame n'est pas
complètement insensible à vos charmes et
à votre en bon poids
bon
[Musique]
en
fait sa route ne va pas débattre avec
vous comme il aime le dire c'est
vraiment voilà on va lui demander on va
on s'est vraiment une interview du
professeur
bonsoir
[Applaudissements]
c'est ma femme ma faim et psychiatre
elle parle avec les femmes donc si vous
voulez vous est génial comme ça vous
prenez un rendez vous chez elle
des duplex au milieu des rafales de vent
l'ouragan ida qui souffle sur la
louisiane donne lieu à des séquences
télévisées très reprises sur les réseaux
sociaux
des journalistes qui doivent gérer des
conditions climatiques extrêmes et
parfois des habitants qui veulent se
faire remarquer
ils sont plusieurs à avoir bravé le
danger comme ce groupe d'amis qui
enchaîne pompe est relevé d'abdominaux
au milieu de la route
vous entendez les rafales avec son mât
dont elle nous avons à nous réfugier
dans cette station de lavage d'une
station service tout simplement parce
qu'il était absolument impossible de
courir sur la route la voiture chasse f
[Musique]
ça fait longtemps qu'ils
mangent en vient pas obligé de dire ça
j'en reviens pas je sais pas ce qu'il
m'arrive
il se remettait de ses fesses ou non
mais t'as vu ce qu'aurait mais moi je
rajeunis 30 ans quand je vois ça la
première fois va 24 ans j'avais tout
fait tout organiser la robe pour les
partis en voyage de noces avant le
mariage à mettre dans la viande
maintenant c'est comme quand il partait
avec sa prof de philo
et le dessus alors le deuxième c'était
plus tard j'avais 37 on est là aussi
c'était tout prévu et là bas
aussi partie avec cette collaboratrice
si seulement dans ma vie j'avais eu la
chance de rencontrer des femmes comme
sakho jallet 25 ans
[Musique]
[Rires]
dieu mon dieu mais chez j'ai visé au nom
de bleu
je suis je suis impressionné c'est très
difficile mais quand je les ai vus se
déhancher là à partir du ray
[Applaudissements]
la fille au lieu de ça d'assumer au et
de s'excuser de se faire tout petit
eagle écrit amont sur ses grands chevaux
est elle sous des douanes de tout effet
sa sainte nitouche c'est une tricheuse
juste un petit clin d'oeil à simone elle
c'est une fidèle téléspectatrice de 7 à
vous elle fête ses 100 ans aujourd'hui
michel il faut lui c'était 100 ans de
votre part simone 100 ans aujourd'hui
regardez ce qu'ils veulent c'est toi
ma chère simone 100 ans c'est bien
après c'est trop